a video of a shoplifter in san francisco
draws national attention to the city's
massive
property crime spree the biden
administration declares white supremacy
america's greatest domestic violence
threat
and president biden preps for his
showdown with vladimir putin i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn
so should you visit expressvpn.com ben
before we go any further
let me remind you you are spending way
too much on your cell phone bill you got
one of the big cell phone coverage
providers
they're basically overcharging you and
this is why thousands of you have
already switched over to pure talk
usa in fact another thousand of you my
extremely wise listeners have made the
switch from your overpriced wireless
carrier
to pure talk over the past couple of
months so exactly what are the rest of
you
waiting for if you're with att or
verizon or t-mobile your family could
save over 800
a year it's a lot of money just by
switching to pure talk you get the same
great coverage because they actually use
the exact same towers as one of the big
carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you will save a fortune by
the way pure talk is the top rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
with the absolute best customer service
team available
they are based right here in the united
states it sounds good it gets even
better because right now you get
unlimited
talk text and six gigs of data for just
30 bucks a month they're saying yourself
what if i need more than six gigs of
data well here's the thing if you go
over on the data they're not going to
charge you for it grab your mobile
phones i'll pound 250 say ben shapiro to
get started
when you do you save 50 off your very
first month now pound two five zero say
keyword ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless alrighty so yesterday
rocketing around the internet was a
video from a walgreens in san francisco
and for folks who have visited any of
our major cities over the course of the
last few years
there's a pretty obvious uptick in
property crime not just an obvious
uptick in property crime
a complete downturn in quality of life
there's a reason that people have been
fleeing big cities
in favor of more outlying red areas or
blue cities in red
states okay san francisco has been
turned from a gem a very
clean and safe city into something
really quite awful
over the past few years you've seen
reports of feces human feces on nearly
every corner open needles on nearly
every corner
in los angeles the homeless problem is
so unbelievably bad that it has now
invaded the suburbs you have people who
are
mentally ill or drug addicts or
basically sleeping on the curbs outside
people's homes
in los angeles this was happening
outside my home in a fairly nice suburb
of los angeles
one of the reasons we moved the same
thing has happened in seattle
used to be called the emerald city now
it's the brown city for all the poop
that is in public
well one of the things that is upticked
in the
recent years has been obviously
low-level crime now people on the left
like to pretend that low-level crime
isn't actually a crime
it's just the cry of the oppressed right
if somebody is shoplifting it's because
poverty is such an endemic problem in
american capitalistic society it's not a
problem of morality it's not a problem
of decency it's a problem of poverty
except that when we see film of people
actually engaging
in crime it generally is not people
stealing the necessities of life just to
get by
more often it looks like something like
this so here is the video from
walgreens you're about to see a young
black man i point out his race here only
because
as we will see san francisco has decided
that they do not wish people to know the
race of the people who are engaging
in crime because they want to avoid
quote unquote stereotyping this ties
into the whole black lives matter
argument
that if there is disproportionate arrest
of particular people
that is not because disproportionate
crime is being committed by particular
people
it is because of racism inside the
system in any case
it's a young black man who is at a
walgreens
and he is just literally shoveling stuff
he looks like he is in the uh in the
soap and pharmacy aisle he's literally
just shoveling stuff
into a garbage bag okay and his bike is
right there his bike is sitting next to
him and you're about to see him shovel
stuff into this bag and then just take
off
there he goes he's just removing
boxes and boxes of stuff putting it in a
garbage bag hopping on his bike
and heading for the door you see there's
a security guy there the security guy
sort of
puts out a limp hand to try and grab the
garbage bag nothing
and there he goes just right out the
door no problem catch you later gang
well people on the left were basically
like well this is the cry of the
oppressed if you looked at the blue
checks
on the left on twitter this is the cry
of the oppressed well except for how
it's not the cry of the oppressed
it is crime and crime is generally not
the the
attempt by the left to suggest that
poverty is the great driver of crime
ignores the fact
that there are impoverished places on
earth where people do not engage
in crime at nearly the levels that
people are engaging in crime property
crime in san francisco
for example they're impoverished areas
of the united states where people are
not engaging
in this sort of crime at the same sort
of levels crime tends to be a problem
of people who are who are committing
immoral acts
especially in a prosperous country like
the united states with a robust social
safety net
there's a to to kind of thrust this off
as this is just
the downside of the american system it's
just the downside of the american system
of capitalism of our white supremacist
system
is ridiculous on its face hey here's how
bad the problem has become in san
francisco again
one of the most left-leaning cities in
all of america
it's become so bad that 17 walgreens
and this happened to walgreens 17
separate walgreens have closed in san
francisco thanks to the shoplifting
problem
in late may a guy named thomas fuller
wrote in the new york times quote at a
board of supervisors hearing last week
representatives from walgreens said that
thefts at its stores in san francisco
were four times the chains at national
average
and that it had closed 17 stores largely
because the scale of theft had made
business untenable
so the narrative that you hear from the
left of course is this is all systemic
racism and that's the reason for the
crime and
then you see stores like walgreens and
they're not being built in in high crime
low income areas and isn't that more
systemic racism and the answer is when
you allow crime to prevail
stores don't move in they undercut the
tax base they make life worse
people don't have places to go crime is
a terrible thing and if you wish to make
life better for everybody in a community
you have to stop the crime at its source
unfortunately san francisco and blue
cities like it are not interested in
stopping crime at source they are more
interested
in blaming america writ large for their
own unwillingness to stop the crime
that is happening within their borders
employees at walgreens apparently have
been told by the leadership of walgreens
to stand aside
while shoplifting takes place like
you're wondering when you watch that
video
why isn't that security guard doing
something to stop that guy like what's
his job actually it turns out his job is
basically to supervise the shoplifting
because walgreens have been told
walgreens employees have been told by
their supervisors
to stand aside because security officers
have been assaulted repeatedly inside
walgreens
now the reason for all of this
particularly with regard to shoplifting
is because of a 2014 california ballot
measure okay that ballot measure
reclassified non-violent theft as a
misdemeanor
so long as the thief took less than 950
bucks worth of material
so you just hit up several walgreens in
a row and you take less than 950 bucks
worth of material and you're fine even
if you get arrested
you'll get off with a slap on the wrist
it'll go right back out on the street
thieves quickly hit on the strategy hit
up a bunch of different stores for less
than 950 bucks worth of stuff
hey then last year i amid the black
lives matter protest suggesting again
that all crime in the united states was
truly due to systemic american racism
and that the police were the real
problem
amid that ridiculous notion
the city of san francisco decided to
double down on its soft on crime
policies
mayor london breed announced that
booking photos would no longer be
released
unless the prevalence of black and brown
faces among the booking photos lead to
stereotypical reactions inside stores
it shouldn't want to lead to racial
profiling so instead what we will do is
we'll just obscure
who exactly is committing the crime that
way if a disproportionate number of
black and brown people are arrested
because
a disproportionate number of black and
brown people actually happen to be
committing these sorts of shoplifting
crimes in san francisco
that must mean that the police are
racist you'll never know any different
because we've never seen the booking
photos in the first place
also london breed announced a 120
million cut to the police and sheriff's
department over the next two years
in the interest of quote prioritizing
investments in the african-american
community
in the first six months of 2020 alone 23
officers resigned
from the force naturally property crime
has skyrocketed and it's not just
shoplifting
burglaries increased nearly 50 year on
year in 2020 in san francisco
car theft jumped 34 in san francisco
meanwhile of course san francisco has
been in a sl
a state of slow motion decline for the
past several years the streets are
littered with garbage
in 2018 there was a survey of 153 blocks
in downtown san francisco
it showed trash like open trash out on
every single block
41 blocks quote dotted with needles and
96 blocks
of the 153 blocks 96 with open human
feces
and again this sort of stuff is not rare
in major cities around the united states
as i mentioned los angeles the quality
of life has become truly awful
the the slogan for for
the for the herbert hoover campaign in
1932 is a chicken in every pot
the slogan in los angeles is a homeless
person on every bench and presumably on
your driveway as well
and again that is not compassion toward
the homeless treating men
severely mentally ill people and drug
addicts as though they have a right to
sleep on the street and use open needles
in front of your children
is not compassion to either the children
or to the homeless people
san francisco by the way is now facing
its worst drug epidemic ever
according to amy graff of the san
francisco chronicle
she says a physician two nurses a
professional athlete a drug dealer and a
lawyer
who had nodded off in court teenagers
specifically a 14 and a 15 year old and
a seven-year-old who got into a stash in
her mother's purse
these are some of the types of people dr
christopher caldwell the chief of
emergency medicine at zuckerberg san
francisco general hospital has recently
seen in the emergency room for medical
issues related to fentanyl use and
overdoses a
seven year old who got into a stash in
her mother's purse
but apparently it's all about white
supremacy gang caldwell said that's just
in the last couple of weeks
it's really remarkable because it runs
the entire spectrum this affects all
walks of life
all folks it's hard to overstate how
impactful it can be to anyone it doesn't
seem to care about race
or background or gender or anything
caldwell said on average about 10 to 15
people who have taken fentanyl are
treated
in the san francisco general emergency
room a day sometimes more
and that's just one hospital in the city
so san francisco which
is famous for being a drug haven has
been for decades is now experiencing its
worst
drug upsurge ever according to the san
francisco chronicle
and meanwhile in new york massive
outbreaks on on subway cars of filth and
feces apparently is according to fox new
york
as people return to the subway system in
new york city they are finding more
trash and filth according to a new
report there has been a rise in soiled
train cars this year according to the
daily news
including cases of feces vomit and blood
the paper cited internal mta reports
an increase in used syringes is being
found amid growing drug use in the
subway system
mta spokesperson andre berman said quote
incidents like this are unfortunate
they're unsanitary for our customers
deeply unfair disturbing for transit
cleaners they're also a reminder of the
need for more mental health outreach and
social service support
in the city and throughout the system
rising crime in the subway system is
also
a problem last month governor andrew
cuomo said people just don't feel safe
riding the trains
they have to feel safe do they feel safe
now no cuomo said at a news conference
the governor said there needed to be
more nypd officers in the subway system
all of which is why according to a new
study from the north american moving
services
the top outbound states for people who
are leaving states in america
illinois new york california new jersey
and maryland
the top inbound states idaho arizona
south carolina tennessee and north
carolina
you notice a sort of political theme
there every single
state from which people are leaving is
heavily blue
every single state to which people are
going is red
or purple at best they'll get to more on
this
in just one second because there's a
move by the left to disconnect
crime from ideology and and that
is a very self-serving move we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let's talk about the fact that you don't
want to go to an auto parts store right
now why would you want to go to an
auto parts store right now you could
instead
just go to rockauto.com see the thing is
when you go to an auto parts you're
gonna stand in line you're finally gonna
get to the front of the line
then you're gonna answer a bunch of very
specific questions and the guy behind
the counter he's gonna type a bunch of
stuff into his computer say oh yeah we
don't have that part in stock come back
next week and we'll upcharge you 30
percent
or you could just do it all yourself at
home and get the part for the best
possible price
rockauto.com will always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same exact parts their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you again
write my name shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you and get the best available
deal
on your car parts at rockauto.com
right now okay so all of this is tied to
ideology
it's tied to ideology in a couple of
ways number one it's tied to ideology
because
the left has decided that crime is to be
overlooked and that if there is a major
uptick in crime particularly in minority
communities
that has to do with america's system of
white supremacy
it has to do with america's deep-seated
cultural racism
that in the end you can always remove
one level and then blame america at
large so if you say okay well
you know i've noticed that a
disproportionate number of people in
minority communities
are engaging in crime they'll say right
because of historic american racism
and you say yes but those people like
right now they are committing crimes in
the moment not because of historic
american racism somebody made the
decision to go to that walgreens and
fill a garbage bag with stuff
and then just take off and they'll say
right because of systemic injustices
right i've said this before but it's
true atheists are constantly accusing
religious believers of using the
quote-unquote god of the gaps argument
the god of the gaps argument is
i can't have any explanation for this
you don't have any explanation
for this thing happening in the universe
this phenomenon therefore god
right we don't understand how the
universe was created therefore god right
this is an atheist say well that's not a
good argument because
obviously at some point that gap could
be filled we could gain further
knowledge and just because there's a gap
that doesn't mean that god fills the gap
it's a fairly good argument by the
atheist okay here is the thing the left
uses the exact same god of the gaps
argument when it comes to systemic
american racism
if there is an imbalance in the crime
rates between communities instead of
looking to
why people are actually committing
crimes or looking to the ideology of
people who are committing crimes
or looking to the ideology of the people
who govern the cities where the crimes
are being committed
instead they just go systemic american
racism they wave their hands and that's
the big problem
in american life well the reality is if
you want to stop
crime if you want to make quality of
life better you need a zero tolerance
policy
with regard to crime you need to say it
doesn't matter
what you think the legacy of hundreds of
years of slavery
was you don't get to go to the walgreens
and knock it over
that is not an acceptable response nor
does it make your community better
beyond that an ideology that suggests
and that there's an excuse
for crime based on systemic american
racism
is an ideology that promotes crime and
that promotes degradation and quality of
life
and and you can see how this works right
it's so funny folks on the left will
suggest all the time
that it's right-wing ideology that
drives right-wing extremism which drives
violence
and then they can't actually connect the
odds because what is the connection
between i want smaller government and
individual liberty
and a white supremacist goes and shoots
up a synagogue
right there's no connection there but
the left tries to make the connection
anyway
but there is a pretty solid damned
connection between
there's an excuse for crime the excuse
for crime means everything except the
criminal
thus we must defund the police thus
there is more crime it's a pretty easy
connection the left just doesn't want to
make it
because if they were to make that
connection they would have to change
their ideology they're not going to
change
their ideology okay so
you know all of this is again part and
parcel of a broader view of america
how you view crime is in fact deeply
rooted in your individual values right
in what you think of the world
this is why the soft on crime left in
the 1960s and 70s decided that riots
were just the voice of the oppressed
and they still believe this it's why
last year all of last year
we saw people making excuses for people
doing two billion dollars
in property damage based on the myth
that police officers are
disproportionately attempting to kill
black people and that there is a
quote-unquote genocide against black
americans
you remember that just last year my
friend amy horowitz he went over
to minneapolis and he asked many of the
protesters about destroying businesses
because
the media particularly white members of
the media
kept saying well you know there's a huge
difference between the protesters and
the rioters and the looters right they
have completely different ideologies
okay and that was true for a lot of
people a lot of the protesters who are
out there black lives matter protesters
they weren't interested in the looting
or the rioting they just were protesting
in favor of quote-unquote police reform
now they seem to have a pretty vague
idea of what that constituted but there
was some separation
but it is certainly true that the
rioters and looters believed the same
things
as the blm advocates and in many of the
blm advocates were making active excuses
for writing and looting including the
current vice president
of the united states who's offering bail
funds for people who are engaged
in property crime i mean you saw people
like nicole hannah jones
bragging openly online that her 1619
project ideology was connected
to the riots that were happening in
cities across the united states who's
celebrating that
just trying to hide the ball there so
as we will see the left has been
attempting to connect quote-unquote
conservative right-wing ideology
to violence for a long time but the more
obvious tie between crime
and violence and ideology exists on the
left and it is affecting cities to the
extent that thousands of people
are leaving these left-wing governed
cities in favor of safer
better places to live and there's a
reason for that and it's because
there are yes a lot of criminals out
there who believe that they are fully
morally justified in doing what they are
doing
one amazing thing about human beings
very few human beings believe they're
the villain of their own story
now the truth is that most human beings
are kind of the villain of their own
story
and most of the mistakes that i make in
my life are my own mistakes right i'm
the villain of my own story i'm also the
hero of my own story we have the
capacity to be both
but most people have very little
capacity to see and when they do
something wrong they're actually doing
something wrong very few people
own their own acts of evil instead most
people blame it on somebody else
and they see their acts of evil as acts
of heroism and so if you're going to
burn down a business
you see that as an act of resistance
against a powerful hierarchy so as i
mentioned my friend amy horowitz went to
minneapolis and he asked
some of the protesters what they thought
of the riots and
the looting and here's what they said
you're not giving it to us so we're
going to take it
of course what do you expect them to do
google
microsoft that's all built up that's all
slavery money
if anybody's a thief it's america so
when we take it back or we burn it down
yeah
we getting back what's odds you won't
give it up okay you ain't having it
almost
okay so you understand what that guy was
saying right there he said google
microsoft all that bs that's all built
up that's all slavery money when we take
it back or we burn it down yeah we're
going to take what is ours he ain't
going to give it up
okay ain't having it no more and the
left has been making excuses for this
sort of idea for a very long time
right there again the the l.a riots were
an la uprising
the violence and looting that we saw
last summer was completely not worthy of
note because after all
it was just a sort of reparative justice
a restorative justice
okay this ideology is damaging to not
just thousands
millions of americans it has real
consequences
the uptick in murder that we have seen
is an outgrowth of ideology it is not
merely happening in a vacuum there's a
reason we saw a massive uptick in
violence last year
in the middle of the pandemic a massive
uptick in murder
in every major city in the united states
governed by a blue state democrat
every one okay the reason for that is
again when you make excuses for this and
when you suggest
that all the problems of american
society can be attributed to the society
writ large
and white supremacy broadly and you make
excuses for this stuff
you get an uptick in this you get a a
real
surge in the destruction of quality of
living
in america's major cities you know the
reason that i bring this up is not just
because of this walgreens video
it's also because what you have seen
from the biden administration is a
tremendous focus these days on quote
unquote white supremacy
so yesterday the biden domestic terror
plan suggested that they were going to
focus on militia extremists and white
supremacy and would include
anti-radicalization training
for retiring military now listen
there are white supremacists out there
who do commit terrorist act
they do now statistically they are quite
rare according to the anti-defamation
league in the year 2020
there are a grand total of 16 murders
committed by white supremacists in the
united states
now every one of those murders is
terrible and horrible there's a country
of 330 million people
and i'm not a person who's downplaying
white supremacist terror considering
that the fbi has arrested people who are
white supremacist terrorists threatening
my family
i was not very far away from the poet
shooting of the chabad
just a few years ago i mean like they're
members of the jewish community who've
been targeted by white supremacist
terror so
i'm not downplaying the threat of white
supremacist terror but if we are talking
about ideologies that are truly
threatening to the american way of life
if we're talking about ideologies that
are deeply connected to endemic violence
in american society
they're like 11 white supremacists in
the united states true white
supremacists in the united states
meanwhile you have an ideology that says
that all of american life is racist and
therefore crime is okay
and that is held by one of the major
parties in the united states and it
governs major cities across the united
states
and has real life ramifications not just
for non-minority members of the united
states population but for all
law-abiding americans who have to live
in these cities and experience the crime
waves
and watch as the institutions that have
facilitated the greatest upswing
in prosperity and freedom in history are
undermined
you wanna talk about dangerous
ideologies that actually have an impact
on american life
white supremacist is a super dangerous
ideology that has very little impact on
american life
the ideology of the hardcore left is a
super dangerous ideology that has a
massive impact
on american life and yet one of these
things is being
played up and one of these things is
being radically ignored not only ignored
downplayed i'll get to that in just one
second first
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you probably face a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role that's why hiring
can feel like trying to find a needle in
a haystack
sure you could post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along and that's
why instead you should try zip recruiter
for free
at zip recruiter dot com daily wire when
you post a job on zip recruiter get sent
out to over 100 top
job sites with just one click then zip
recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zipper crew is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day it's no wonder over
2.3 million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options zip recruiter
finds you what you're looking for
the needle in the haystack like right
now there are a lot of people who are
looking for a job
and maybe you have a bunch of applicants
for that job you don't know who to pick
zip recruiter helps you out
with that process every step of the way
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again remember go to this
unique place ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-re zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire
alrighty so the joe biden domestic
terror plan is now
focused like a laser on white supremacy
joe biden said in a press conference
quote the national strategy for
countering domestic terrorism lays out a
comprehensive approach to addressing the
threat while safeguarding bedrock
american civil rights and civil
liberties
values that make us who we are as a
nation we cannot ignore this threat or
wish it away
the outlet noted that the national
security council has now defined
domestic terrorism as quote activities
that involve
dangerous acts to human life that are a
violation of the criminal laws of the
united states or of any state
appear to be intended to intimidate or
coerce a civilian population
to influence the policy of the
government by intimidation or coercion
or to affect the conduct of a government
by mass destruction assassination or
kidnapping and occur primarily within
the jurisdiction
of the united states domestic terrorism
is both persistent and evolving and
requires an overarching
approach okay so all of this
is worth targeting right i mean anybody
who's trying to engage in violence on
behalf of a political ideology
ought to be targeted by this but you'll
notice that the focus
has honed in specifically on white
supremacy now again this doesn't mean
that there is no threat from white
supremacist terrorists it means that if
we're going to focus
on the threats to everyday americans
coming from people or fomenting violence
on behalf of a political ideology
and we're going to rank those threats
white supremacist terrorism
is not at the top of the list all these
threats we can walk and chew gum at the
same time but
i've noticed that uh we are not walking
and chewing gum at the same time we are
chewing gum and not walking at all
although domestic terrorism can focus on
a wide range of ideas racially or
ethnically motivated violent extremists
and militia violent extremists are
assessed as presenting the most
persistent and lethal threats
the nsc said adding many domestic
terrorists unite around anger with quote
the same segment or segments
of the american community including
persons of color immigrants jews muslims
other religious minorities women and
girls
lgbt lgbtqi plus individuals
or others the nfc does include anarchist
violence extremists who violently oppose
all forms of capitalism within its
pantheon of potential domestic
terrorists
to address but apparently they are
focused
really strongly on the on the white
supremacist
terror threat now again if we were just
sort of looking
at terror threats generally and then
assessing each terror threat and then
fighting all terror threats that'd be
one thing
because again terrorism unlike just
regular everyday crime
is deeply intertwined with ideology but
as
i am saying there's one ideology that
the left wishes to ignore
when it is tied to violence we all know
what that ideology is
okay merrick garland who's the new
attorney general yesterday i was
testifying
and he said that the top domestic
violence extremist threat comes from
white supremacists which is
kind of an amazing statement given the
fact that we've seen an uptick in murder
across
the nation numbering thousands of
murders across the nation over the
course of the last year
connected to a deeper root belief
in the systemic nature of american
racism we have seen 2 billion
of damage done last year alone in the
vast spate of rioting connected to
ideology these were outgrowths of the
actual protests
and yet apparently the only threat that
is worth talking about is the white
supremacist terror threat
again you don't have to download one to
to talk up the other
you can talk up both but i've noticed
that we're not talking about both we're
only talking about one it happens to be
the one that is responsible yes
for a certain number of murders in the
last year
and we are downplaying the other one
that is responsible for the collapse of
major american cities here is mara
garland
according to an unclassified summary of
the march intelligence assessment
the two most lethal elements of the
domestic violence extremist threat
are racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists
and militia violent extremists in the
fbi's view
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
okay so that is the greatest domestic
violence threat in america
not just terrorist threats domestic
violence threats
in america okay i
no i mean no just statistically no the
greatest domestic violence threat that
is tied to ideology in america
is not coming from white supremacists
it's coming from people who believe that
there is an excuse for violence across
the nation
rooted in america's history of racism it
is it is it is the group of people
in government in the halls of power and
yes
on the ground committing acts of
violence right now committing crimes who
blame that on american racism
and suggest that the violence is
justified because you know what america
sort of deserves it
and again it's amazing how how people on
the left will actively downplay this
threat because it is so closely tied to
some of the things that they promote
so merrick garland says don't worry guys
we're not focused on ideology this is
not an attempt to crack down on ideology
we're just focused on violence purely
and specifically
we are focused on violence not
on ideology in america
espousing a hateful ideology is not
unlawful
we do not investigate individuals for
their first amended
amendment protected activities we do not
prosecute people for their beliefs
across the
world extremist or terrorist
labels have at times been affixed to
those
perceived as political threats to the
ruling order
but there is no place for partisanship
in the enforcement of the law
okay so he's saying at least we're going
to preserve free speech in
all of this right that's really what
we're going to do now i have a question
do you trust them to preserve free
speech
truly considering that every time there
is a a
domestic terrorists white supremacists
the entire media rush to condemn the
entire right
hey do you trust that this
administration is really going to
preserve first amendment rights
i have some trouble believing that they
are interested in preserving first
amendment rights
and first amendment rights do in fact
apply to everyone that apply to blm
protesters the same way they apply to
white supremacists
i hate all of that okay i hate all of
those ideologies
that does not mean that they don't have
rights okay but again
this is there is in a political
motivation
to ignoring one problem here that is
much larger than the other problem in
terms of size and scope
and depth of effect on everyday american
life
and again i just keep pointing this out
the disparity
in what the left is willing to
acknowledge about ideologies that are
closely tied with its own and their
connection to violence
and what they are willing to focus on is
pretty astonishing
to take an example andy mccade yeah
you'll remember
you'll remember andrew mccabe andrew
mccabe of course was uh one of the
he was the former fbi agent who was tied
into the russia investigation and he
engaged in in ridiculous acts that ended
up basically
i believe losing his pension anyway
andrew mccabe
was on cnn yesterday talking about this
and uh and he said well you know we
still don't know what motivated the
congressional baseball shooting
interesting he brought the other side of
the equation
into it by referring to the shooting of
the congressional baseball practice
and he did it very carefully by saying a
shooting by someone
only who committed a shooting only after
he confirmed
uh that the players were republican so i
think that reflects the fact that the
fbi still doesn't exactly know what that
shooter was up to they never
really uncovered the sort of detailed
evidence
that laid out a specific plot or an
objective but it is undeniable
that he was targeting republicans
again and andy mccabe suggesting there
that the fbi still doesn't
didn't know what exactly motivated this
i know the fbi knows full well the guy
had a list
in his pocket of republicans he was
shouting this is for health care while
he shot republicans
so yeah we kind of know but the the
temptation by folks on the left to
downplay violence so long as it is
linked with their side
continues to astonish and dismay
because that does have some really
negative impact and i got a
an email the other day from a member of
our military
so the military right now is undergoing
all sorts of violent extremist
training uh violent extremist threat
training
so that means that they're sat down and
they're put through powerpoint
presentations about the evils of white
supremacy and be on the lookout
for people who are being recruited into
white supremacist groups
and this member of the military raised
his hand and he asked the training
commanding officer
he asked him okay what about blm and
antifa and the training commanding
officer said
no those are not extremist groups those
are just philosophies
yeah sure alrighty
coming up we're going to get into joe
biden facing off with vladimir putin
first let's talk for a second about the
fact that the stuff that your kids are
watching and learning on tv is largely
garbage we talked last week about how
nickelodeon
is openly propagandizing on behalf of
lgbtq causes to very young children like
three to five-year-old
children well it's time to tune out of
that and tune in to prageru
prageru has launched a massive new k-12
education
program thousands of educators and
parents have already signed up check it
out at prageru.com forward slash
kids prageru has tons of free kids shows
and books magazines with the
pro-american values that aren't being
taught in schools
or most kids shows the prageru website
has everything you need to get your
young family through what's happening in
our country right now do you want your
kids to learn about our nation's
founding principles and be proud of them
how about passing on values you care
about like truth freedom responsibility
hard work
and equality under god if you want your
kids consuming content that actually
supports your values go to prageru right
now
show your children their animated shows
books and magazines most importantly
support prageru in their efforts to take
back
america's education i know prageru for a
long time in videos with them daily wire
is basically a sister company
with prageru now go check out prageru's
children's education materials right now
really awesome stuff
subscribe now don't miss prageru's
incredible free kids content visit
prageru.com
forward slash kids today already in just
a second we'll get to joe biden facing
off with vladimir putin first
as the woke mob continues to ramp up
their attacks on american culture it's
become incredibly clear the only thing
standing between our freedom and their
brand of authoritarianism
is us and that is why i wrote the book
the authoritarian moment it is a vital
book okay what i'm talking about right
now the destruction of america's major
cities
the destruction of basic necessities
like safety and security
and individual rights that's all
happening because the left has taken
over our institutions and are now
weaponizing those institutions
against your rights and your safety and
your way of life
okay the only way to fight back against
that is to know how to retake those
institutions that's what my book the
authoritarian moment
is all about it's really an important
read i wrote it
just a couple of months ago at white
heat i think you're gonna need to read
it i think it's how we fight back the
authoritarian moment is now available
for pre-order
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller
also leaving the left is a journey all
liberals should make georgia hal is one
of the few who's been leading the way
you'll remember georgia she's a former
teacher and liberal who brought her
expertise on ideological indoctrination
from the classroom to the daily wire
she's now started
her very own show office hours you can
now listen to that no matter where you
are
in podcast form whether she's discussing
critical race theater with james lindsay
or transgenderism with abigail schreier
she's constantly talking with some of
the most fascinating people
in american public life the people the
media won't let you hear from so
subscribe and download office hours with
georgia how on apple podcast or
whatever your platform of choice may be
get ready for the ultimate listening
experience no matter where you are
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile joe biden is meeting
with vladimir putin today and
it is going exactly as you would have
thought he is sitting there with note
cards i'm not kidding you he's sitting
there with note cards and reading off
note cards
while vladimir putin stares him down
like the bond villain he is it's just
unbelievable
i mean joe biden is not with us he's not
been with us for quite
some time and um you know that's not
great
joe biden yesterday said that he was
always ready i was born ready
yes but you were born so long ago that
you don't know the meaning of the word
ready anymore here he was yesterday
before the meeting explaining that he
was ready for his meeting with putin it
turns out not so much
okay somebody said are you ready for my
own joe biden said i'm always ready
first metamucil okay so here is what has
been happening today a reporter
a asked president biden directly do you
trust putin
do you trust each other president biden
is requiring yamiche alcindor official
spokesperson for the biden campaign
president biden looked directly at the
reporter and nodded affirmatively
oh good and then kate bettingfield
the white house comms director had to
walk it back she says it was a chaotic
scrum with reporters shouting over each
other
the president was very clearly not
responding to any one question but
nodding an acknowledgement to the press
generally
he said just two days ago and his
pressure verify then trust oh so he had
to walk it back in real time by the way
many many many reporters
reported exactly what yamiche alcindor
reported
meanwhile caitlyn collins the cnn chief
white house correspondent tweeted it was
very hard to hear
but president biden referred to u.s and
russia as two great powers in the
opening of his summit with putin
he mentioned areas of mutual interest
where they can cooperate and noted being
quote unquote predictable
and rational when they don't agree so
just crap all over trump is really the
theme
of the of this thing but i mean putin is
just
eating biden's lunch basically because
biden is not with us anymore
it is fairly incredible that we are
supposed to just
ignore the fact that that joe biden is
being softer on russia than donald trump
by like a long shot
a long shot again jennifer jacobs she
reported the same thing
right bloomberg news she reported the
exact same thing as yamiche alcindor
quote us pressed asked biden if you
trusted putin
the president nodded yes reporters again
asked putin why do you fear that lexi
navalny who's the
the center in russia who's been in
prison is probably going to die in
prison and what did you do
if ukraine joined nato no putin answer
so putin's just sitting there giving
nothing
and biden's like i trust this guy who is
he again
wow this is going great by the way you
know what is is worth noting here
i was very critical of president trump
for doing foreign meetings with foreign
dictators without any sort of
goal of deliberables and there are a lot
of people on the right who are very very
happy with president trump meeting with
kim jong-un well look at that he stepped
over the
the dmz line over in in korea and he's
writing love letters to kim jong-un
i said this is stupid there is no point
to this not only is there no point it
grants kim jong-un legitimacy on the
world stage he legitimizes him with his
own people
if you're going to have an international
meeting with an adversary there has to
be a goal attached to the meeting these
are not just fun get-togethers where you
get together and you play backgammon or
something
you go there with an agenda in mind and
then you seek to achieve the agenda and
if you don't you usually get your lunch
eaten
okay so if i said it about trump i'm
certainly saying about biden too biden
met with
putin for no reason at all they didn't
go there with an agenda they didn't go
there
seeking any deliverables from vladimir
putin it was just a chance for biden to
get a photo op but the problem is
that even biden knows he was going to
get his lunch eaten and his mint his
milkshake drunk
by by vladimir putin and so instead he
was downplaying it but he's like i'm
doing a photo op with putin but it's not
a photo op and also we're not going to
do anything
but it's kind of a photo op it's just
amazing stuff
and we're supposed to ignore the fact of
course that uh that joe biden
is is not with us it's very important
that we ignore this
according to em the washington post
vladimir putin's first interview with an
american television news outlet in three
years was
perhaps strategically so a big hit for
russia's networks the russian
president's one-on-one with nbc has been
widely aired and much discussed across
state media platforms in it
putin dropped a russian schoolyard rhyme
in response to one question and alluded
to the satirical soviet novel
the little golden calf in another
references for a russian audience rather
than an american one
as putin was pressed on issues including
moscow's cyber attacks against the
united states
and whether he orders the killings of
his political opponents his tone was
dismissive
at times nonchalant it mirrored the
kremlin messaging at home ahead of
putin's plan summit with president biden
in geneva on wednesday
putin agreed to this meeting at the
request of the americans but will not be
ceding anything
russian officials and propagandas have
repeatedly said they do not expect the
summit to produce
any big breakthroughs for a u.s russia
relationship that has hit a post-cold
war low
they've worked to portray putin is going
into it from a position of strength
because
because he has little to lose or gain so
what exactly are we even doing at this
meeting what is the point of this
meeting
the answer of course is to pretend that
joe biden is a world leader who is still
sentient but he is not
there's a reason why tom cotton center
from arkansas said this sit down is a
very bad idea because it is a very very
bad idea
i would not be going into this summit
tomorrow i think it was ill-advised
for the president to make one of his
first major
bilateral summits overseas with vladimir
putin especially
after this string of weak actions
towards russia
the president should have spent more
time this weekend focused on china and
the threat that china poses
and bringing our european allies along
with us to see that threat
as opposed to talking so much about
things like climate change
russia remains a threat but china is the
threat
that the united states and really the
free world faces in the decades ahead
and meanwhile the the biden
administration is doing nothing about
china either so unless you think that
it's just about russia they're doing
nothing about china either they continue
to promote public statements made
by the europeans that don't actually
have any teeth to them
in fact the left is too busy being angry
at anybody for mentioning the wuhan lab
league theory
remember joe biden started taking it
seriously last week and then said maybe
we should have like an intelligence
committee investigation
on all that we'll get our intelligence
people together they'll investigate all
of this
this was the same day basically that a
report had been revealed that he had
shut down such an investigation that had
been begun
under the trump administration meanwhile
robert redfeld the the former cdc
director he says the scientific
community acted to squelch the wuhan lab
league theory while i was over at the
cdc
it just seemed like a lot of people
wanted to squelch any idea
that there was another hypothesis and i
think that's what i find
the most disappointing because i would
expect that from politicians
i would expect that from governments
i would never expect that for the
scientific community
and yet what we witnessed was the
scientific community went on heavy
to try to stop any open debate about the
origin of this virus and i find that
this very very sad very disconcerting
and very anti-science
according to redfield by the way anthony
fouch is one of the people who is less
than interested in investigating the lab
league theory in the first place
i think tony is holding on to this
hypothesis tightly
now why why would that be sometimes
scientists
when they get on they bite into a bone
on a hypothesis
it's hard for them to move on i guess if
i'm disappointed about anything about
the early scientific community
is that there seemed to be lack of
openness to pursue both hypotheses
now what's amazing about all of this
again you've got
joe biden not being able to face up to
vladimir putin things are going very
poorly over there joe biden
who literally glitched in the middle of
the eu meetings and he was over there at
the g7
and he just glitched for a second time
and you know how bad his glitch was we
played a clip yesterday
of joe biden answering a question his
gap
in thinking was so long that i had to go
back and re-insert myself saying
wait for it wait for it for radio
because otherwise there was so much dead
air
that they would have taken the show off
the air that's how bad the glitching is
from joe biden meanwhile what is the
left focused on
they're not focused on the fact that joe
biden is not really with us or the fact
that joe biden
is busily ramping up the inflation
they're not worried about the fact that
joe biden is about to have russia eat
his lunch
now they're worried about the fact that
jon stewart said some true things about
wuhan lab league so yesterday
jon stewart was on stephen colbert and
he said some funny and true things about
the wuhan lab league situation
and um and the media's response was how
dare jon stewart do this thing
i think we owe a great debt of gratitude
to science science has in many ways
helped
ease uh the suffering of this
pandemic which was
more than likely caused by science
now stuart went off on this a little bit
more and again
it was not well taken by the left
respiratory coronavirus overtaking wuhan
china
what do we do oh you know who we could
ask the
wuhan novel respiratory coronavirus lab
the disease is the same name as the lab
that's just that's just a little too
weird don't you think and then they ask
those scientists they're like how did
this
so wait a minute you work at the wuhan
respiratory coronavirus lab
how did this happen and they're like a
pangolin kissed a turtle
okay meanwhile so how did the media
react to jon stewart their favorite
person doing this
piece in the washington post today by
paul waldman
quote john stewart's rant is a reminder
don't rely on celebrities for covet 19
theories
oh weird because five seconds ago you
were telling us that every celebrity in
america needed to be relied upon for a
covet 19 theory so long as it was
anti-trump
it's truly it's it's an incredible
turnabout because
bottom line is for the media whatever
effectuates the agenda of the biden
administration
is worth promoting anything that does
not effectuate that agenda
is not worth promoting at all now this
is leaving some fairly large openings
for joe biden's political opponents
because it turns out that you can only
hide the truth for so long and then
people start to get
a little bit skeptical of what you are
telling them yeah the
the left is trying to shut donald trump
out of politics
and meanwhile by creating this bubble
around joe biden it just makes it easy
for trump to
bust through that door like the kool-aid
man and just pop that bubble
perfect case in point today donald trump
is now going to head down to the us
mexico border
because kamala harris won't according to
the daily wire ryan svedra reporting
former president donald trump announced
tuesday he is traveling to the u.s
mexico border as president joe biden's
border crisis
has continued to worsen and vice
president kamala harris has repeatedly
avoided traveling to the area
i've accepted the invitation of texas
governor greg abbott to join him on an
official visit to our nation's decimated
southern border on wednesday trump said
in a statement
the biden administration inherited from
me the strongest safest most secure
border in u.s history in mere weeks they
turned it into a single
worst border crisis in u.s history it's
an unmitigated disaster zone
if this weren't bad enough biden and
harris won't even tour the scenes of the
wreckage they created or come down and
visit with the border patrol and ice
heroes risking their lives to defend our
nation
at a time when the white house is doing
everything it can to make their job
totally impossible said trump what biden
and harris have done and are continuing
to do on our border is a grave and
willful
dereliction of duty so yeah they're just
pushing that door
wide open for trump or frankly any other
republican with half a grain of sense to
walk
right through it so i guess the good
news here is that in their
blind attempt to cover for their own
ideology to cover their failures
with their own ideology um they are
opening the door wide to the blowback
and the blowback is most definitely
coming
alrighty we'll be back here today with
an additional hour of the ben shapiro
show
in the meantime go check out the michael
moles show today he's discussing the
senate making juneteenth
a federal holiday you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show that is available right
now i'm penn shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam's scie events audio
is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the senate makes juneteenth a federal
holiday
chuck schumer calls a kid and
firebrand gop congressman marjorie
taylor green
apologizes maybe for the first time ever
for something that she said check it out
on the michael knowles show